But we are engaging now in several
research projects.
We started out with a study in
Parkinson's disease,
so we're working with a bay area
Parkinson's,
a treatment center,
and they also have researchers there.
Um,
but the way that works is that if you're
a part of 23 and me,
you can fill out the online surveys that
we have and you can fill out any ones
you're interested in.
And they're not just all really serious
research.
There are some fun surveys to fill out
about are you left or right handed idea,
blue eyes,
Brown eyes.
Um,
and some of these features that we hope
to also discover the genetics for which
there's so much to be learned.
Um,
so we're in the process of running more
and more of those research experiments.